and uh daisy talking of co-stars must
mention you
and your new friend uh barbara streisand
oh
oh yeah it was amazing you know those
things that you said
where did you meet the oscars or
something well basically
jj who wrote and directed episode 709
he had said oh i'm friends with barbara
you know in l.a everyone's friends with
everyone i think
lovely and he said oh she wants to meet
you i was like this is never going to
happen what's going on
anyway i don't know how it happened but
i'm in her house
and the worst thing was she had this
honey thing right and and i thought the
honey
you know when you push the thing and
then you pull the honey like that oh
yeah but i did honey and it almost came
out in her
18th century french and and she said ah
do you want to be on my album this whole
time i was thinking this is real like
what
i'm going to wake up like what so anyway
i left thinking sure
went back to la for the oscars and i
recorded a song with her
it's on the album and did you get to do
when you went back away
oh right i mean i was definitely the
weak link on the song
i'm not missing the chance to sing with
barbra streisand and when you're in the
house did you get to go to the famous
shopping mall i didn't go to the
shopping mall but i i had seen like
[ __ ] she had sort of shown me around
but i had to catch a flight
and i was so sad because i'd heard about
the shopping mall i wanted to see it
it was honestly and then i got this
email saying do you want to come to
barbra streisand at hyde park i thought
[ __ ] yeah i want to go to bob's this
whole time you're thinking like this
isn't
real like what's going on and then
afterwards everyone goes and sees her
she's like daisy i'm like
even talking about i'm like it's not
real a mate she's
amazing obviously but like really
amazing
[Music]